hello everyone hi welcome to my talk
dotnet data security or net cord they
discuss a hope is not a strategy hi my
name is stephen haunts and big privilege
to be here it's a remarkable job that
NBC and dylan have done making this
conference go virtual with such short
notice so massive respect to everyone
involved okay so let's get started so my
name's Steven haunts and I'm a Microsoft
MVP for developer tools I also run a
training company called Steven Tom's
training although most of my in-person
training is canceled at the moment and I
also do training for Prosise I have 21
almost 22 courses on the site so the
reason I'm doing this talk is I believe
it is a developer's responsibility and
when you're working at an organization
to look after your company's data and as
software developers we have quite a lot
of power and responsibility during that
quite often we see this kind of very
blasé attitude towards companies and
that they think they're not going to get
hacked or attack you know have any kind
of data stolen and really what they're
doing is hope is not a strategy
basically so I'm hoping that you're not
going to get attacked I'll have someone
steal your data credit card data custom
data it's just not a strategy and you
know it could be mixtone or attacker
back in from the outside like we see in
the films or it could be a member of
staff finger is disgruntled with the
company happens to have sequel Turner /
sequel admin access and select stars
around a date swings to a spreadsheet
now these attacks can happen from pretty
much any any angle so the hope that
you're not going to have a problem is
not strategy a quite a lot of time and
certainly what I've found in projects as
well is that really when you're working
on a large-scale project security tends
to get pushed back and back and back in
the development cycle because it's not a
big visual feature business people they
know security is important but it's not
something they can normally touch and
fill so generally it gets pushed back
which is a real shame so what is
talk or what is not about say so it's
not a talk about mathematics which is
good because I'm rubbish at maths and
it's not a talk about how to break
cryptographic ciphers and it's not about
the CIA the FBI in what his talk is
about it is about people like me and you
you go into companies every day sit down
we write code and you know just like
everyone else we're under tight
deadlines we have to get stuff out and
sometimes a lot the security stuff
really isn't that straightforward and
it's not generally that well documented
and you'll see from some of the class
names today some of it is a bit cryptic
itself in dotnet which is kind of ironic
so what we're talking about is kind of
you know nets but that core dotnet
framework and generally a lot of the
stuff gets used on the server side
although you can use the in client side
as well now when dotnet call first came
around sort of around the dotnet called
1.1 here don't know standard 1.6 a
majority of the cryptographic protocols
or algorithms that we wanted to use
we're not their core which meant thought
they call it wasn't really at the time
robust enough for the enterprise but
when we got stop make call to their
standard to which things around summer
2017 that's when things really changed
so we started to get quite near you know
feature parity with what was in the
original data framework and now is where
you know going through future versions
of.net are actually getting more
primitive to being added in so this talk
is mostly about Microsoft technology
it's about dotnet and on that core and
but really the principles of what we're
talking about kind of transcend any
platform so just because we're looking
at specific but on an API what we're
talking about it's just as varied in PHP
Python Swift Ruby api's would be
different but generally things are going
to look very similar okay so what we're
going to
so we're gonna cover quite a lot today
this is gonna be quite a packed hour so
I appreciate everyone's probably very
tired and this is probably to make you
even more tired so we're gonna start off
by looking at random numbers then we're
going to look at hashing and H max or
hash message authentication codes then
we're going to take a little detour and
talk about passwords and bring a talk
about symmetric encryption using AES
we're gonna talk about asymmetric
encryption using RSA and then we're
gonna talk about digital signatures and
once we've covered all of the primitives
we're going to start using some of them
together so you know look at how we can
you know combine so many different
primitives to build something bigger so
what we're going to end up looking at is
we're going to build a little what we're
going to show a little some kind of
theoretical demo of a system with Alice
and Bob what to send a secure message to
each other Rikard me a very simple chat
so education now as I said we're gonna
cover quite a lot quite quickly so if a
lot this stuff is very neat to you and
if it gets the end of the talk and
you're certainly thinking yourself oh my
god this is too much
don't worry treat this talk is kind of
an art of the possible week's kind of
gives you a little glimpse into what you
can do with encryption and cryptography
I'm going to provide you lots of
resources that you can go away with
again talk if you want to and I'm gonna
give you lots of code resources you can
download from github which are very easy
to use and I want to give you lots of
book and sort promo cycles
recommendations as well I think if this
is kind of like your intro into the
world and then I'll give you lots of
stuff that you can use afterwards so
saying that this is where a real
conference people will be putting their
phones out and taking a photograph the
screen but the github repo I've got
there contains all of the code from one
of the versions of my workshop so I'll
do a one day workshop and all of what
I'm talking about today is contained in
that workshop and so if you do download
that zip file or you clone the
repository in the complete folder and
you can basically download the solution
that's in there it's all donate call
compatible and all of the examples in
there all self-contained console
applications so they're very easy to run
build one and step through and it
contains everything that we're talking
about here so if you do want so you know
spend a bit of time but your leisure
going through some of the stuff
in there a case of weights cryptography
so generally we think of it as
protecting information we have some the
information we want to hide it from
people or you know make it unreadable
you do that using encryption encryption
Germany uses something called encryption
keys the results of what we encrypt is
called ciphertext and the art or the
science of trying to break cryptographic
algorithms called cryptanalysis
but there's kind of more to it than that
so cryptography basically falls down
into four distinct pillars so we have
confidentiality have integrity of
authentication and non-repudiation so
confidentiality is you know making
something confidential so you can't read
it
integrity is about checking if something
has become corrupted or has been
maliciously tampered with so we can look
at some primitives for that
authentication is about checking whether
someone has permission to to do
something call check something which is
kind of an extension to the integrity
model then we're going to look at it's
not an appreciation which is a good way
of thinking about this it's kind of like
a contract so if you sign a contract
with someone there's some work safer I
don't know thousand pounds or thousand
euros if you complete that work and then
try and say no you're supposed to pay me
two thousand euros you have a contract
in place so that you sort of one person
can't refute it this is going to be
computer equivalent that so cryptography
is used pretty much everywhere you
cannot get out of bed in the morning
without some kind of crypto going on so
online shopping if you use Amazon or any
other websites
Jemmy that's going to be behind you know
TLS and they're gonna have lots of
encryption going on with all your card
details when you use the cash machine I
guess many of us actually using cash at
the moment but when the good old days
when we used it more cash you put your
card into the Machine you type your PIN
number in there's a cryptographic
handshake going on between that machine
and Bank to prove that you are the
person who owns that card and then you
can withdraw your money smart phones
these days especially Apple I'm not
quite sure about Androids I don't use
one but you know soon as you switch the
phone on pretty much everything is
encrypted locked down
but then this kind of some other options
as well so things like Bitcoin and all
the other 4,000 different types of coins
are out there they're all based around
cryptography and how they work and also
electronic voting systems starting to
spring up as well which use cryptography
now I'm not going to get into an
argument about whether electronic voting
is good or bad and but it is an area
that is being used okay so let's start
with our first primitive which is random
numbers so random numbers are pivotal to
everything we do in security they are
basically what we used to generate how
encryption keys now one of the easiest
ways to generate a random number
Humanity's two systems at random and if
you're trying to roll the dice or
generate lottery numbers then system dot
random is perfectly fine if it generates
a non deterministic encryption key
system that random is not very good a
better one to use and a more deliberate
one in the API to use is one called RNG
crypto service provider which is in the
system security cryptography namespace
as is everything else that we're
discussing today very easy to use I have
a little bit of sample code here so we
have a method called generate random
number we pass in a length which is a
number in bytes so if you want to focus
you by the number you pass 42 into there
instantiate the class you create a new
byte array of our design them and we
call get bias passing in that byte array
and then we get it filled with lots of
random data just great and then that
gets returned as a byte array pretty
much everything we're doing in the
sample code you see today uses byte
array so sometimes you have to do a bit
conversion between byte arrays and meet
basic 64 encoded strings but
fundamentally we're dealing with
batteries at its core that's found a
number that's very simple is seven or
eight lines of code next one is hashing
so a good way of thinking of hashing is
it's a bit like creating a fingerprint
for a piece of data so if you have
cumin say a PDF and you run hashing
algorithm over it you're gonna get a big
long number out back there and actually
algorithm so that number is called a
hash it is kind of like a fingerprint if
any of that data changes in that PDF
document so someone changes a name or
even if you just trained one single bit
in that document recalculate the hash
the entire document will be completely
do what the tire hash will be completely
different this is a good way of checking
integrity of files and data that we send
across the internet so there's four
general principles or general guidelines
for a hash algorithm so first of all it
has to be easy to compute I have some
data I pass in and data hash it we get a
hash code out the back it should be
infeasible to generate a specific hash
so you can't start with a hash and go
hmm a piece of data do I need to
generate the hash you can't do that it
should be infeasible to modify a message
without changing the hash so going back
to my PDF example when if he changes one
single bit any of that file in the hash
code will be completely different and it
should be infeasible to find two
identical hashes so if you have two
pieces of data or two to PDF files you
generate a hash code for both of those
files and the hash code is the same then
unless those documents are identical you
shouldn't be able to do that that's
called a hash collision some older
algorithms like md5 do exhibit that
problem another good way of thinking
about hashing and a good way of framing
the mental model around is when we talk
about encryption it's a two-way
operation so he has some data encrypted
with a key decrypt it in the same key
data backs it's two-way hashing it's
one-way so you can't find a hash for a
piece of data and then reverse that hash
into which update that's impossible to
do it's also what guess is one of the
interesting unique properties around
hashing there's lots of different
though one that we were all probably
familiar with his md5 and used quite a
lot on UNIX and Linux so this produces a
16 by hash value it was designed by ron
rivest in 1991 and you know for a while
it was quite well regarded but in 1996 a
collision resistant vulnerability was
discovered where he know you can had two
different pieces of data that generate
the same hash it's still worth talking
about
today because if you're integrating with
an older legacy system you may still
have to calculate md5 hashes at the
sample code I pointed you to at the
beginning of the talk now there are
examples of md5 in there so I works for
a bank in the UK one's called egg and we
had a very old of as400 you know
mainframe system that sat in the back
and data that was passing between those
systems regularly had to do md5 hash
checks between the data so if you're
working for an older legacy company or
legacy system you might still need to
use it so then we have what's called the
Shah family or the secure hash algorithm
family and it's very different variants
that we have support for in.net so sha-1
juice is a 20-byte hash or 160 bits in
sha - you can generate hashes at 256
bits in them which is 40 bytes or 512
bits after 64 bytes there is a newer one
called char free and the main
fundamental differences that char 1 and
char 2 had the involvement at the NSA
when they were designed which actually
makes people in little nervous these
days so there's a competition to find a
new hashing algorithm where the NSA
isn't involved and that was based on a
cipher called kakaka finkley's
city known as our name but it's
effective what's become char free now
this isn't natively supported on that
call yet and I imagine it might come at
some point in the future but at the
moment is not you can find C sharp based
open-source implementations of it but
I've seen you need to use anything like
that at your peril and that's a
discussion you have with your security
officer but we're going to look at today
we can use sha-256
so again it's very it's very easy to use
most of what we're looking at today is
actually quite easy to use so have a
method here compute a sha-256 we pass in
a byte array of the information we wants
a hash so this could be you know how PDF
file that we've loaded up into a byte
array we call the static create method
on the sha-256 class and then we call
compute hash passing the data that we
want to hash and that will give us a
bite already back that we return so in
this case it'll be 32 bytes in them so
that was hashing so there's a kind of a
metallurgical step for hashing called
authenticated hashing now this is very
very similar so as you see we have green
boxes the hashing algorithm we pass some
data in we get a hash out but in this
instance we also pass a key into the
hashing algorithm so for example one
we're going to look at the keys 32 bytes
in them so what this means is that if I
hash a piece of data I have a key I then
send that piece of data or that hash
code and a piece of data to someone else
if you want to calculate that same hash
you have to have the same key if you
pass the different Keynes weight you're
going to get a completely different hash
code out the back this is why we call it
hashing so if you think of it you know
your mental model is that the keys come
like a password you both need to know
the password to create the same hash
this is where the authentication aspect
comes in so all your recipients have to
have that key now sharing these keys is
very very difficult we're going to talk
about that later
under mentally for now everyone that
wants to recalculate that same hash has
to have the same key yep so this is
for verifying both integrity and
authentication integrity in that we're
calculating a hash for a piece of data
we can easily tell if a piece of data
has been tampered with because a hash
will change and hash codes or H facts
are based around md5 and the char family
just as we looked at before and strength
is based on the length of the key so the
longer the key you provide it the more
secure this thing's going to be so the
most common attack against H Mac is a
brute-force attack which is where you
try you know billions of combinations of
keys and so you get the one that you
want I'll see the longer the better
okay very simple to use looks kind of
similar to what we looked up before so
we have a method we pass in our data
that we want to hash we also pass in our
King Mikey's going to be a 32 by its
random number in this case generated in
the same way that we looked at earlier
if RNG crypto service provider so if you
want to do a sha-256 based HVAC we
instantiate the HVAC shanty 56 class and
we passed a key into its constructor and
once we've done that we call compute
hash and that objects asking the dates
that we want to hash and then out pops
our hash on the other side so very very
powerful concept what it lets us to but
just a few lines of code to use it which
is fantastic so what we're talking about
hashing on take a little sort of detour
and down the road of passwords something
that affects us all
so securing storing passwords securely
is very very important you know you have
to look every day when you see Troy hunk
posting on Twitter there's some there's
been some massive data breach and hole
loaded passwords have been stolen or
maybe you've signed up for have I been
pounding you see if one of his password
and breach emails I've had that seven
times so storing passwords is very
important because they do get stolen and
people do manage to reverse-engineer
them very very easily which we'll look
at in a moment so the way that we store
passwords in our system is you're doing
it by hand is very very important
there's two common attacks
we can use against passwords one is a
brute-force attack this is where you try
billions and billions and billions of
combinations of passwords until you get
the password and to hash it so you get a
password that produces the same hashes
we could store in your database
typically passwords are stored as hashes
so brute-force attacks what's it sounds
like a big job is actually becoming
easier every year I mean when every time
and video releases a new gtx card mms
you know we use graphics hardware as the
means for brute force in passwords as
comments all for doing it is a tool
called hash cat very easy to use you can
just download it you can download a
dictionary from somewhere or you can get
it to brute-force the password and it
will just transfer away cracking
passwords for you ever attack is called
a dictionary or a rainbow table attack
and fundamentally what this is is it's a
pass it's a file which could be multiple
gigabytes in size which has my chevy
single password you can think of and all
of the variants you know what we tried
to be clever by changing bowels into
numbers and sticky and exclamation marks
around to the place no attackers are
thoughts of all this they're not stupid
so all of these combinations are in a
dictionary and then all that's all a
hash caster there is he just looks in
the dictionary it's literally just a
dictionary lookup a good way of
demonstrating this if you're trying to
scare people in your organization's to
take passwords security more seriously
so as a website here called crack
station net this is quite a nice little
tool so you take a password so in the
gray box here we have a sha-256 password
you paste it in there you fill out the
CAPTCHA hit crack hash as you can see
here in the green at the bottom is
worked out that it is a sha-256 hash and
the password of secret 69 and on this
same website you can actually make them
a few dollars of work free agent you can
actually download the dictionary that
they use on the site so what we talked
about here then is you know the most
common way of storing passwords is to
take a password the user types in you
hash it with a sha-256 and you store the
hash in you date that's been a very
common way of doing it for years now
normally when I can see the audience
people put their hands up and tell me
over there companies do this home do you
see that many video feeds on so we won't
bother so the next common way of doing
this is what's called a salted hash now
this is fundamentally very similar
except what we do is we append on to the
password something called a salt and the
salt is just a piece of entropy that you
add on to the password so it could be a
few digit number or it could be a 32 by
random number that you append on to the
password your hash the password and then
you store that hash in your database but
you also have to store salt as well
maybe not necessarily in the same table
as the password but you do need to store
it somewhere so that when the user me
types in their password on a system you
look up that user you bring bet you know
you pull back their salt combine it with
the password do the hash and in check
with what's in the database
this is incredibly common I'd say
probably you know 50 60 % the companies
out there still do this and that's fine
and the problem with this though is
whilst that might be a secure password
now and they might take you know haschke
decades to try and crack those passwords
as GPU hardware gets more powerful and
did you know that the rates in which gtx
or nvidia AMD cards is progressing is
quite scary what might be a secure
password now with this salt in five
years time could be not secure as a big
problem
so there's another technique that we
want to use which is called a
password-based key derivation function
sounds lovely
or a pbkdf2 you want to really impress
people with acronyms what it's doing is
actually quite simple so it's the same
as before we have a password and we have
a salt but we also have a number which
is called a number of iterations so if
you pass 10 a number of iterations it's
gonna rehash that password with the salt
ten times before it gives you the final
password if you put 10,000 in there it's
going to hash that pass for 10,000 times
what a million in there to do a million
times and the reason this is important
is because what it's doing is its
algorithmically slowing down
at hashing process so instead of hash
cap you know what's crack say a billion
passwords a second you might slow it
down to a thousand hundred ten one it
depends on what that value is he what's
in there so I'm sure you've all seen on
some websites when you log on to the
website you type in username and
password and it shows that there's kind
of like a 5-6 second delay before
anything actually happens behind the
scenes they're probably doing something
like this you're probably waiting for
their pbkdf2 function to run and it's
this is a great way of doing it because
it's slowing down that password hashing
process so if you want to do this in net
it's very very easy to do now there's a
class that we use called RFC two eight
nine eight derive bytes there's a lovely
piece of class mainly if you're
intimately familiar with RFC spec
numbers then that completely makes sense
for the rest of us normal people who
aren't familiar with RFC spec numbers
it's a bit confusing so if you click
through the documentation for dotnet
you're probably gonna skip over it
because you just doesn't make sense
generally that is incredibly easy to use
which is great so in our method we have
the password to be hashed you have our
salt as a battery and we have an
iteration number that we pass it so we
instantiate RFC two eight nine eight -
I've bytes past those three values in
and we call get by it's 20 that gives us
our hash code back and a reason we
passed 20 in to get bytes is because
high in the scenes the RFC to eight nine
eight spec use sha-1 to do its hashing
which gives you a hundred and sixty bits
hash code back which is 20 bytes Oh
spec specifies a sha-1 so that's what
Microsoft is implemented so you only
need to bring back the first 20 bytes
once you've run that you then go and
store your password in the database
along with the salts as previous and
your system obviously needs to know what
the iteration counter is so that's
probably can be stored in some secret
convicts on we're now quite
the original version of this talk I did
some timings on a much slower laptop
time I'm using today but it kind of
illustrates a point so hundred
iterations at the time took two
milliseconds a thousand took 16
milliseconds right the way up to half a
million which took seven seconds seven
seconds you might be thinking no way am
I going to make my users wait seven
seconds so what you need to do is you
need to have a conversation between your
security officers organisations and
people in the business and you have to
work out what your tolerance to that
delay is going to be a company might say
- eh okay well three seconds is okay and
or if your Amazon they might say well no
that's three seconds he's like a billion
billion dollars twice so you need to you
know check that number or check what not
be one to use over time you may want to
change that number so as servers and
computers get faster no if you had half
a million as your iteration count today
five years time I see that could be a
lot shorter in length so organizations
I've worked in so we might have had say
a hundred thousand as our iteration
count and then we wanted to double it
say every year - um yeah five hundred
thousand one easy way of doing that he's
dead
if you want to do a gradual rollout of
those changes then you just have a bit
of logic in there that says you know
when your user logs in you automatically
invalidate their password and then you
spin them some yarn about how we want to
improve our security get them to type in
their password again rehash it and then
store it or you could have a more brute
force attack system we and validate
everyone's passwords and then try and
get them to reload back in that's
probably the easiest way of doing it
this is Shirley
of Ashley Madison it's been discussed at
conferences for quite a few years and if
anyone's not familiar with Ashley
Madison it's a dating web sites the
encourages people to have affairs not
particularly pleasant websites and but a
few years ago they had a big data breach
maybe coordinated attack against them so
all of their dates are stolen including
all of their passwords and behind the
scenes and they try to crack these
passwords they found that they use a
system called beat crypt for hashing
their passwords a beat crypt is face
similar to what we've just looked at at
the past web based key derivation
function interface wise it's the same
data to hash assault iteration number
how many differences these beat crypts
uses the Blowfish I think it uses uses a
different algorithm internally doesn't
matter they used an iterated hash
function which is good but I have a
problem if Ashley Madison as they also
stole the source code which is a big
problem as well so they broke through
the source code and they found that some
enterprising developer may be a junior
developer you know but come along and
tried to optimize the logon process so
when you logged in it would then cache
an md5 token if you password so the next
time you log in if you had that token
you could just check that instead it
would lock you in faster which someone
who doesn't know how these things work
seems like you know a fairly reasonable
optimization once it found this out and
knew where the tokens were they manage
to go reverse at 90 percent all of the
passwords in their database Scherzer bit
of a problem for them there's a link
here to an ARS technica article that
kind of goes through this whole actually
matters something in a lot more detail
and really interesting I highly
recommend reading it okay so and
to look at then is symmetric encryption
I hope everyone's still following me so
far how will you see anyone on the
screen you'll get your camera's office
there in mind okay so you spoke
encryption the way this works is we have
some data we encrypts with a key which
gives you your cipher text or your
encrypted data then use the same
encryption key to decrypt the data and
get original data back that's why it's
called symmetric it's the same key for
both increase and decrypt now encryption
this ways is good in one way it's very
very fast its algorithmic it's what
computers are good at and but a problem
is sharing those keys between people is
very hard I mean how do I get my
encryption key to someone they wouldn t
mail it probably not gonna send you on
whatsapp or to get in the database
somewhere so there's a particular
problem of symmetric encryption but the
actual speed of him having symmetric
encryption is very very fast so as I
said before going back to our mental
model but as we've said hashing was one
way
encryption is two-way as he wants you
out to recover they to be encrypted and
a weighted symmetric encryption works is
it encrypts several bytes at a time
so these bias called blocks Oh blocks
are padded so each block is the same
size so if you've got a piece of data
and you say got a block size of 128
bytes once you get to the end if it
doesn't quite fill up on from 28 bytes
or get padded no listen there's some
known data for zeros so in dotnet all of
our encryption algorithms derive from a
class called symmetric algorithm so the
one that we care about today is AES
crypto service provider but we do have
implementations for DES crypto service
provider and triple des of crypto
service provider so those are much older
encryption algorithms not recommended
for use from new systems as I said
before if you're integrating with
something there's a lot older in legacy
and you have to decrypt and there's
encrypted data is handy to know how to
do it but because each of these
algorithms inherits from that same base
class the interfaces are the same so
once you know how to use one know how to
use all of them
so a yes it's a is a standard with the
National Institutes of Standards and
Technology became a standard in 2001 so
it's quite old now and it was designed
by two Belgian mathematicians so Joan
Damon and Genson Roman and it's based on
a cipher called lime now some of you may
say that there's wine they'll manage
class in Nets as well as a is crypto
service provider
fundamentally they're both the same
pretty much the same and it was based on
the wind-down cipher so the way this
works is if you want to encryption data
we pass in our plaintext so by its rays
are they to answer encrypt you're
passing something called an
initialization vector which in this case
is going to be 16 a 16 byte andum number
and that's used to help actually
kickstart the encryption of the first
block now that number that IV is not a
key it's not secret you don't treat it
the same as you treat a key but you do
need to store it because when you go to
the crypts your data you need to pass
the same IV into AES and we have three
key sizes we can use 128 bits 192 bits
or 256 bits we're just gonna go straight
for 256 bits there's the bigger the
better so you pass those free things in
you run the algorithm and you get your
ciphertext out the other side
Swink Nets you've got two versions of
this class you've got a EES managed and
AES crypto service provider I've -
exactly the same thing and I'm most
likely gonna keep exactly the same
results the main difference is that IES
managed is a native dr implementations
it's raining pretty sharp you know it's
an i/o based implementation but it's not
it's not a certified implementation so
there's a ratification process called
Phipps and it's Phipps 197 - - so this
version isn't online 7-2 certified
whereas AES crypto service provider is
now this uses the underlying windows
crypto platform off using.net call on a
Mac it uses erm secure SSL this one is
35 now what that means is it's been
officially tested so that means if I
encrypt some data on my machine here in
botnet core and pass it over to another
system that's implemented in Java and
their version is Flip certified we can
guarantee that they're gonna be able to
decrypt my data I send them and vice
versa that's what that certification
means so slightly more complex to use
this is probably the most complex piece
of code we can look at today so we have
our in crypto effort your party now data
to encrypt you pass in how key is a byte
array and we pass in our initialization
vector which is 16 bytes instantiate AES
crypto service provider here I'm
explicitly setting the keys and we
create a memory stream in a crypto
stream because it's stream based which
means you can create very large amounts
of data we pass the data in we call
crypto stream got write and flash remedy
to array and then that gives us back our
encrypted data now encryption decryption
is very very similar so most of that
code is to say that's difficult to point
to the screen but the line here where it
says new crypto stream Open bracket
memory OMA it says AES crates decrypt
are there whereas on the previous slide
it so it creates encryptor that's the
only difference you quit the stream
write it flush it all to array that
gives you your original data back as a
byte array so if it was text so if it
was occur I know someone's name it from
a database you'd probably pull that
backers and you'd have it as text you
convert it to a byte array you encrypt
it then you're probably going to base 64
encode that results story database and
you want to decrypt it you're gonna know
i'm base64 encoded it back into a byte
array it crypt it and then convert it to
back into normal string now in dotnet
to the current versions of.net something
called free there's different modes of
AES that we can use and only use one
called AES cipher block chaining mode
which is kind of insta for mode and
typically what we do is in normal usage
what we do is we encrypt some data using
AES and then using the same key we
create a hash Mac of the encrypted data
so then we know that once we've sent our
data to our recipients if they've got
that key they can check the hash Mac
first to make sure the data hasn't been
tampered with if it hasn't they can then
decrypt it that's called an encrypt and
then Mac in the latest version of.net
core we have a new mode is called GCM
mode which is called Gallinas cancer
mode so what this basically does is it
takes that hashing process at the ends
but it does it internally
whilst it's encrypting which makes it
quite fast and efficient and you'll get
in your hash Mac by default oh this
looks slightly different to use but it's
quite straightforward so here we have
some texts that ones have encrypt so
mary had a little lamb and we pass in
three pieces of data and we have a nonce
which is basically fundamentally the
same as the initialization vector but in
the spec it's called a nonce nan borns
in this case is 12 bytes we pass in our
key just said you did perform and then
we can also pass in something called
associated dates and this is just
metadata the and passing along if you
are around data that you want to encrypt
typically when I've used I've just
passed it null I never said satiated
data in imagine if you had a customer
record name address telephone number
that sort of thing the Associated data
might be the king my defend database
example she passed all of that in and
just realize I've got a mistake on this
slide and I'll explain do you run all of
that you get your cipher text at the
bottom but you also receive another
piece of data out of it called a tag
which is a byte array of data now that
tag is your hash mark so you're
receiving two things back out of this so
needs are going to fix that slide choose
G
mode you know it's nice and easy which
is great so we have our encrypt method
we're passing our data to encrypt
passing the key passing the nonce which
is 12 bytes so random number you
generate a new nonce every time you
encrypt and data and we have our
Associated data so then what I do is I
pre initialize some arrays so you have
the tag which is 16 bytes so the hash
Mac we get back is 16 bytes we then
initialize an array for our cipher text
we creates the AES GCM class by passing
in K we call encrypt where we part in
our nonce and ASA to encrypt the cipher
text array we want to fill the tag that
we want to fill and the Associated data
and that gives us back our cipher text
and our tag populated so we need some K
so I'm just returning a tuple or a
topple and are you forming the world
that gets returned back to the client's
so to decrypt what we do is we pass in
what looks like 100 math things into our
methods and pass in our cipher text
that's an encrypted data the party in
the original key we passing the original
nonce that was used to encrypt the data
we pass in the tag if he was given the
encrypt method you're passing the
Associated data parse all that into a
decrypt method and then we get our data
decrypted so if any of that cipher text
has changed or the tag has been modified
or the nonce has been modified or you
pass in the wrong key obviously not
reversal decrypt data so all those
things have to be the same ok
a symmetric encryption so this is
fundamentally we were trying to achieve
the same thing we try to take some data
trying to scramble it in a way so that
people can't read it and we wants a way
to decrypt it way this works and we've
things like RSA is he sort of having one
key but have a key pair a public in the
private key so what we do is we encrypt
with our public key and then our
recipient decrypt with their private key
so if I'm saying
in my data to fix on in the audience is
Jessica I'm there to pretend I was here
she said she was going to turn it on so
if I wanted to send some data to her I
would request her public key she'll send
that to me it's public anyone can know
it's I didn't quit the data with her
public key send her the encrypted data
and then she would use her private key
which only she knows to decrypt that
data that's how things like I race how
you work this was developed by RSA data
security incorporated by Rivest Shamir
and Adleman into name RSA the way this
works is based around very very large
prime numbers of modular arithmetic and
it's based on that way there's no
efficient way to factor a very large
prime numbers so a minimum recommended
kilo piss about 2048 bits the case
they're quite big and per typically you
might use 4096 bit keys now RSA it's a
mathematical encryption scheme and there
is a limitation you can only encrypts
data up to the size of the key so if
you've got a 4096 bits okay you can't
encrypt some piece of data and larger
than that which is a little bit of a
limitation and you could say oh I could
just get my data and split into lots of
chunks and encrypt those but you
probably are gonna want to do that
because RSA is the same you slow about
something like AES so as I said it's
based around prime numbers and prime
number factorizations so if I said to
you and you know what's 23 times 17s
that's easy work it out in your head on
a calculator it's 391
now if I Saturn man and say what two
prime numbers do I multiply together to
make five thousand nine hundred
sixty-three normally I make the audience
wet at this point trying to work it out
and but I'm not going to do that now
it's much harder to do so the answer is
67 times 89 five thousand nine hundred
and sixty three so people now back into
our key analogy so the public keys to
five thousand nine hundred and
sixty-three it's the easy bit and the
bit that was hard trying to work out
those two prime factors is the private
key so go mad
you know I'm sending some dates it's
Jessica she would have both of those
keys I would request her public key five
nine six three encrypt the data send it
to her and then she uses her private key
67 times eighty nine to decrypt the data
so all sounds a bit complex it's
actually very easy to use so if I want
to generate the key pair public and
private key I create class called RSA
crypto service provider passing my once
well then call RSA dot X for parameters
false it's gonna be the public key and
then RSA export parameters true give me
the private key it's kind of interesting
API design there I've seen true and
false to get the public and private key
less that's kinda how it works and
dotnet which encryption data now that
we've actually generated those two keys
so I pass in my data that I want to
encrypt I then instantiate RSA crypto
service provider I import my public key
recipients public key and I then just
call RSA encrypt passing in the data it
gives me back encrypted data if we now
assume that I've sent that data to my
recipients they come along and they
instantiate crypto service provider RSA
crypto service provider the imports
their private key it's their key only
notes they call decrypt by passing in
the encrypted data and they get the
encrypted by its way back out you have a
random they get the decrypted by its way
back so that's yeah it's quite easy easy
to use very very powerful uses his
ability to have this split key system
which we're going to come on soon why
that's useful a moment just quickly I
want to
primitives by looking at digital
signatures so a digital signature is
something that's based on RSA it uses
the public/private key scheme a good way
of thinking of a digital signature is
you can have a piece of data and you can
have how it digitally signed with
someone's private key so that if anyone
further along tries to refute that data
that they've been sent because it's been
encrypted or signed with a private key
you can kind of prove who signs that
message a great way of thinking about
this is if you've used any websites like
DocuSign where you can go on and sign
contracts what they're staying behind
the scenes it's creating digital
signatures so that if anyone signed the
contracts on their own buying house or
car you signed you're gonna pay one
Valley but then you try and refute it by
saying you want to pay a different value
that document is we mathematically
signed which you can use as evidence in
court which is quite handy so three
parts of a digital signature we have key
generation we have signing algorithm and
a signature verifier so the way this
works in so what we want to do to create
digital signature now we talked about
the limits with RSA in that you can only
encrypt ops and size the key length
that's the same with a digital signature
so what we do first is we get our data
that we want to sign then this could be
a PDF of contracts that people have no
physical e signed or whatever we then
take a hash or hash mark of that and
documents we then sign the hash and that
gives us our digital signature so if we
look at my brilliant piece of arts here
so we have Bob so Bob gets his private
key and he creates a digital signature
he sends that he sends that digital
thing shows the internet and then Alice
here uses Bob's public key to verify
that our signature is true or not now
when we talked about RSA we talked about
the fact that you encrypt with the
recipients public key the main decrypt
with their private key so here is the
other way around so the sender is using
their private key to basically create a
signature and then the recipient is
requesting his public key to verify that
signature
it's me so generating keys for digital
signatures is exactly the same as what
we saw before and we'll cover that again
so then to sign the data so we pass in
the hash of the data that we want to
sign we instantiate RSA crypto service
provider we imports the private key and
then we have to create a class called
RSA pkcs1 signature formatter brilliant
piece and Vern asked naming we then have
to tell it what hashing algorithm we're
using internally so obviously we we're
passing in a hash so to set that we had
to pass in a magic string that says
charlotte's you 56 in lap case
kid you not then what we do is we call
create signature you pass in that hash
and then what that's going to do is it's
going to return a byte array about
digital signature so we've digitally
signed our PDF we've sent it to someone
and they want to verify their signature
is valid so what do they do so they take
the hash of the data and we send them
the hash we send them the signature
which is calculated the imports the
originators public key we then call RSA
pkcs what we then least and she ate RSA
pkcs1 signature D formatter it's
formatted before an HD formatter
again we take what hashing algorithm we
use in so sha-256 and then we call
verify signature and that will return
true or false true if it's a valid
signature false if it's not
okay so I'm gonna need to I'm gonna need
to get a wiggle on hex we're running out
of time so we have quick recap so
confidentiality we look to IES and RSA
integrity we look to char 256
authentication we look to H max and
non-repudiation we looked at digital
signatures so each of those four pillars
we now have a very simple primitive that
we can use satisfying those pillars so
what we'll do now is we'll combine some
of these together now as I said before
we like this it's gonna go reasonably
quickly and if you are interested in how
this works download the source code I
said at the beginning I'll give you the
link at the end post it into slack
because I've got very
simple console apps with all of this
stuff in that you can run and step
through really easily so I have it
encryption so RSA has limits on the
amount of data you can encrypt discuss
that but what the flexibility and speed
of AES sharing keys is hard so what we
can do in this first instance is we're
going to combine our essay and a es and
what we're going to do is we can have
Alice and Bob and they're going to send
a message between each other in a secure
fashion so what do we do then so we
start off we take our or we generate an
Aes session key it's just a 32 by E that
we're going to use for this particular
conversation we encrypt our message
using that session key using AES just
like what we looked at before then what
alice is going to do she requests Bob's
public key he sends it to her and she
encrypts her own session key with RSA is
in Bob's public key
she sends her encrypted message and her
encrypted key over to Bob and an
initialization vector as well why should
hurt Bob then uses his private key to
decrypt the AES key once he's done that
he can then use that IES key to recover
the original data ID krypton it with AES
a fundamentally that's quite simple so
if it was imagining that as a packet of
data or a class of data we have our RSA
encrypted session key that we send him
we have our initialization vector I just
realized I left off the previous diagram
and we have our AES encrypted data so
let's run through this as quick example
it's go place walk through the problem
ok yes Alice generates an aes key
there's two bytes she generates an
initialization vector 16 bytes she
encrypts her message using AES session
key and the initialization vector she
encrypts the session key using Bob's
publicly packages it all up sends it
over to Bob and he receives a message so
he takes that
he uses his private key to decrypt the
session key he's now got the original
session key back he then uses that
session key and initialization vector to
decrypt the message so the messages meet
me at noon blow the clock tower where a
red rose in the model
what we've done here then is we've
managed to get a symmetric key between
two people securely using RSA that's
that's the benefit we've got so Bob now
wants to send a reply so he generates a
new key so every session he created new
clean he creates a mission a new
internationalization vector encrypts his
data using the key in the ivy he sends
its crypts of session key of IRS I use
analysis public keys he's had some
requests Alice's pocket key this time
crypts that sends it across Alice
receives a message and now she wants to
decrypt the message so she uses her
private key to recover the session key
she then uses that session key and
initialization vectors decrypt the
message it says I will meet you I'll be
wearing a blue hat and red boots
I'll be very fashionable like Bob great
so we've got data backwards and forwards
between two people relatively easily
using RSA and AES brilliant what can we
do now so we want to add integrity into
this now so exactly the same as what we
did before except we had this orange
blob in the middle so once we've
encrypted our data once we've encrypted
the key using the recipients public key
then create a hash Mac of the ciphertext
in an initialization vector now we
create a hash Mac because we have access
to that session key so well known as we
use it to create the hash mag we then
saw that hash Mac in a packet of data
and then on the other end
Bob has to use when he has to decrypt
the session key first with virus on his
private key once he's got the session
key he can then recalculate the hash Mac
to make sure it hasn't been tampered
with
if he's happy he can then go and decrypt
the data so again
as packets of data that we're sending so
we have the encrypted session key
initialization vector the encrypted data
and a hash mark of the encrypted data
and the IV now this example here B is
using AES in cipher block chaining mode
so if you're using if you have to use an
older version of AES uses cipher block
chaining or you've got some legacy code
or an older version of.net so this is
how you do it if you didn't call three
you would use AES GCM moment now the
beauty of GCM mode is it does that
hashing process for you internally so
our original diagram it we have here
looks very much like the original
diagram and that we looked at at the
beginning of the hybrid encryption
section so if using GCM you don't need
to do that additional hash process which
is good but you would have slightly
different packet that you sense you'd
have your encrypted session key you'd
have the nonce you generated you'd have
encrypted data and you'd have the tag
which is effectively that H map right
let's go one step
so we've conquered confidentiality as
we've managed to encrypt data and
managed to swap the keys we've used
integrity and authentication because
we've used H Mac if we're internally in
GCM mode or manually so we have
integrity and authentication you have to
be in possession of that decrypted AES
key to cut that same hash Mac that's
authentication if any of the data has
been tampered with then the hash Mac
isn't going to match the one that sent e
you recalculate it so that gives you a
gritty as well so let's add a digital
signature into the mix so what we do
here is once we've calculated that hash
Mac H Mac we can then pass that into a
digital signature algorithm carried it's
a digital signature using the recipients
private key so that means that when I
get sent across to the recipients they
then have to use the sender's public key
to calculates the digital signature but
they can't do that until they've
decrypted the session key so they
decrypt the session key they check that
the hash value then by recalculating it
if it is they check whether the
signatures valid if it returns true and
then go and decrypt the original message
now that sounds like quite a lot we went
through that quite quickly but as I said
if you do want to play around with it's
not actually that complicated once you
start stepping through some code so I do
encourage you to downloads sample code
just have a play around with it I've
tried I've documented it all fairly well
I think I might actually start playing
around with it it actually becomes quite
a bit clearer and what we discuss here
is kind of a very rudimentary way in
which a very simple you know two-way
chat system might work and the way that
you're sending data between people also
if you think about when you're using a
server you know you on the internet and
then it's a secure website using HTTPS
so you've got a TLS connection going on
what it just describes is very similar
to what TLS is so your server or your
website and the server will negotiate
initially they will work they'll agree
what ciphers they use in so they might
go let's use RSA let's use AES let's use
hash max 256 so once they've agreed on
the protocols they're going to use
you know your machine will then creates
this session key it encrypts it send it
across to the receiver so that means
they've got the session start in turn
only traffic you send over HTTPS is
going to be using that symmetric key
that's already been shared a similar
principle ok we've covered quite a lot
here so that's what we've gone through
today I'm not going to read through it
all again you've gone through it at
length and but the stuff that's in
dotnet is and many other systems it's
very powerful when you get to start
using this stuff and it's actually
fascinating so if you are still
interested after this is some things
that you can use so there's three really
interesting books here so the first one
on the Left code book by Simon Singh is
written for mere mortals to understand
and it's kind of like a history books it
starts from ancient times and it goes
from what way for you to reasonably
modern times it's a fascinating read and
my wife is horrified once when I read it
on the holiday it kind of reads a bit
like a novel book in the middle every
day cryptography eyes what an advance
books and the first half talks about all
the premises we discuss today but it
tells you how they work in terms
quite an in-depth book and the second
half of the book talks about how they
used every day so one section in the
book talks about how cash machine on ATM
negotiates with the bank and it goes
into a lot of detail how that works
fascinating book that is quite heavy
going applied cryptography on the right
there is the book that in the 90s the
NSA tried to ban basically you know back
in the day encryption algorithms run it
out to be exported from the US that were
classes munitions and this book
obviously upset a lot of people it goes
into a lot of detail about how or not
these algorithms work it doesn't cover
AES and fortunately because it wasn't
around time if you've liked maps and
your glutton for punishment there's some
really good books to look at if you're a
pro star subscriber I've got a few
things that you might find interesting
so my course practical cryptography net
and basically goes through what we've
done today but at a much slower pace
with a lot more explanation it's about
of course and I'm about planning to
update this course soon to make it
fleece or net core so example is you
download and the demos are doing that
course our doctorate framework but apart
from the project fellow differences most
of the code is completely identical so
the course is completely valid and by
own plane to update it I'm some point
soon well at the back play-by-play
enterprise data encryption if as you
revealed is of course a typical answer
Clint's when we talk about Asia key
volts anyone's interested in that and
its last course here blockchain
principles and practices is of course I
wrote about blockchain and the main
principle of the course is that if your
CI CTO turns around to you and says I
want a blockchain if I seem to do quite
a lot this course tells you exactly how
they work what it's all about and it
builds up an example blockchain in
c-sharp using some of the techniques
that we've discussed in this talk so if
you think of this course is a bit of
ammunition that you can have in your CTO
city one's a blockchain you'll give you
the ammo you need to tome and say even
yes that's a good idea or no that's a
terrible idea
no he's normally the correct answer so
thank you very much affirmation to
finish one minute before the end that's
quite amazing and I have a blog that
Stephen haunts come I'll blog about all
sorts of things I've got a on Twitter
and of Steven haunts be great to
interact on there maybe once this whole
pandemic nightmare is over maybe I can
come back to Porto another year and I
can bum my two day that you've got my
two days security workshop which you
might find interesting
apart from that thank you very much for
having me I know she doing a virtual
conference has been very hard for
everyone it's a lot of screen time for
people and a lot of us speakers have had
to grapple with how to do this but I
think it's gone fairly well so again
thank you very much to NDC and didn't BT
pulling this all together and thank you
very much to everyone for attending I
thank you